hey what is up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and yes the wallpaper
link is in the description either way
welcome to tech channel of the week
number nine uh the original mkbhd video
series and this channel is
jailbroke touch 95
and i'll go ahead and give you a quick
tour of this person's channel uh now
that they are tech channel of the week
number nine and uh basically this
channel does a number of uh tutorial
videos i know you guys are interested in
both hardware and software as long as it
has to do with technology
but this channel yes does have quite a
bit to do with tech so i'm just going to
give you a quick tour of it right now so
if we scroll down i will just give you a
rundown of the specs of this channel and
uh yeah it does have a pretty nice
background if you haven't already
noticed and is running uh youtube 2.0 so
that's nice
either way has
3195 channel views matt has 11 000
watched videos and he has 262
subscribers and uh his website i don't
really uh feel the need to show you his
website because there's not that much on
it but if you do want to check it out uh
the link to both his youtube channel and
his website will be in the description
so anyway if we go back up to the top
here you can see uh one of the more
prominent things about this channel is
that it does have 89 video uploads 89
videos guys so if we go ahead and hit
see all here and scroll down you'll see
there are a lot of videos here not all
of them are jailbreaking uh the ipod
touch videos i don't know how you do 89
videos on that but uh there are a lot of
tutorials
on this channel now they are mac os 10
tutorials and our ipod and cydia and all
that kind of stuff but trust me if you
go ahead and search through using the
video search box up top which i've
encouraged you guys to use
you'll definitely be able to find some
topic you'll be interested in watching
watch a few videos on that uh so if we
go ahead and go to the most viewed
section and watch in the grid uh his
most um his most viewed video is
actually what to do after you jailbreak
your ipod or iphone and i could that
could be interesting to a few guys who
have successfully jailbroken your ipod
or iphone not that i you know encourage
it or anything uh but if you do what you
know what are you gonna do now that
you've jailbroken install a few themes
install a few applications that aren't
in the app store etc um other videos
that he's got up here in his most viewed
list are um
his uh 3.0 jailbreak update uh how to
make a vista pc look like a mac so i'm
guessing he also has a vista pc uh and
you know he has his intro video and all
that stuff up here so i'm just going to
go back to all videos he also does have
playlists so if you want to go check out
his playlists just go ahead and hit that
playlists button on the right hand side
and uh yes i will be doing it to a tour
of the youtube 2.0 layout quite soon
guys so stay tuned for that uh anyway
there are pc tutorials and ipod and
iphone tutorials and if we go ahead and
check out the pc tutorials
there are 24 videos in this series so
there's definitely not a lack of content
guys you guys saw how many videos are on
this channel uh there are 24 tutorials
in the uh mac and the
windows category of his tutorials as
well as about
a lot of other videos about other topics
uh so i'm going back to his channel a
few other things about it
uh if we go and look at his featured
video uh how to get uh album art for
itunes with no credit card and i've
actually used this tutorial to get a lot
of my album art not that i i don't use
it that much i do have an ipod nano uh
but if you do have an ipod touch or
something like an iphone where you
actually do browse and cover flow a lot
you might be interested in uh checking
out that tutorial right there and i do
rate these these types of videos five
stars uh also guys get a good look at
this background you might want to ask
him how he made this background or what
he used because it's pretty pretty
pretty cool looking right now
uh if we scroll further down here you
can see he you can see that he does have
a twitter youtube broke up the link
because you obviously can't have too
many links on your channel uh but he
does upload his um sorry update his
video views daily and he's closing in on
25 000 right now and uh he's his twitter
i'll go ahead and throw his twitter link
in the description so the three links
you'll see in the description are his
youtube channel his website and his
twitter
uh but that is basically it guys that is
tech channel of the week number nine
jailbroke touch95 you guys can check him
out in the description he does have
quite a few nice videos a few uh
tutorials a few
ipod videos if you have an ipod touch
check it out and that is basically it
guys so thanks for watching i hope you
like the combination of software and
hardware i'm maintaining here on this
channel and uh if you have any questions
or comments or you just want to get
noticed for the next tech channel of the
week episode leave a comment below tell
me what kind of videos you do tell me
what you like uh what you'd like to see
featured in the next channel tech
channel of the week stuff like that guys
so thanks for watching thanks for uh
maintaining great channels i'm still
putting together a list of tech channels
that i'm considering so if i say hey
you're on the list
you know i'm considering your channel uh
so anyway thanks for watching again and
thanks for rating hopefully you did rate
this video and that is it thanks guys
peace